ce quartier résidentiel de nikolaev est
à nouveau touché par des tirs de
missiles du haut de cet immeuble il ne
reste plus rien plusieurs habitants
perdu la vie les secours déblais
l'hermine à chaque nouvelle attaque
ces derniers jours il ya eu de plus en
plus de frappes sur les quartiers où ce
coût des civils mais nous sommes prêts
nous sommes prêts à faire notre travail
prenez ça et vous pouvez prendre de
l'offre
comme après chaque bombardement la
solidarité s'organise c'est la troisième
fois que ce quartier est visé depuis le
début de la guerre aux infos les russes
distille bond des néo nazis ou si on
sait néo nazis sont que des personnes
paisible aj qui sont restés
comment pouvons nous vivre dans ces
conditions
à quelques dizaines de kilomètres vers
la ligne de front se trouvent des
villages anéantie mais où certains
habitants sont restés
avant la guerre la population était
d'environ 1350 personnes ici et
maintenant moins de 2 % sont restés
environ 30 personnes
la chose la plus effrayante de ces
derniers jours c'était le moment de
silence
avant les bombardements était constant
sur cette ligne avancée les soldats
ukrainien défendent fermement leurs
positions
le terrain est miné
mais c'est du côté de la modernité de
l'équipement que le bât blesse c'est le
cas avec cette mitrailleuse maxime
produite en 1944
attention aller de l'autre côté
c'est fini les combats l'canyon ont dû
partir
notre pays est en train d'utiliser
toutes ses ressources toutes ses forces
nous attendons une aide de réelles et
rapide pas des mitraillettes maxime je
mets des armes modernes
les forces je craignais mènent une
contre offensive pour tenter de
récupérer la ville voisine de red sonne
entre les mains des russes depuis mars
dernier